hey there folks we're continuing on with
little educational videos for pride
this time we're going to talk about
non-binary lot to cover let's see if i
can do it in time
so if we're going to talk about
non-binary let's establish what the
binary is the binary view of gender is
male or female two options that's a
binary now the first thing to realize is
that there are way more options than
that available for gender
and anything that does not slot cleanly
into male or female is
a non-binary identity which does mean
that like trans
non-binary is in fact an umbrella that's
the other thing i want you to take away
from this
non-binary is not any one thing there's
sort of a
a bit of a cliche and stereotype that
non-binary means
androgenous presentation it means they
them pronouns
it can mean that but not necessarily i
mean my identity as a genderfluid person
is a non-binary identity because
i have times where my place where i land
is in between those two options so it
covers a lot of ground
and i hope this helped